this was during a scheduled court
appearance in a corruption case
these are the images of him being
arrested you can see him there in in the
white at the front of that group of
Security Services being put into a
vehicle
and this arrest comes just months after
the former cricketing Legend and
political figure was also wounded in an
assassination attempt he was ousted in
this no confidence vote back in April
and he says that this move to Aston was
illegal it was a western conspiracy and
he has campaigned against the government
of his successor ever since that's the
current prime minister
Sharif he has demanded early elections
and he says that this is all part of
this conspiracy against him